lipitlere başlıyoruz su içerisinde
çözünürlüğü az polar olmayan hidrofobik
yani suyu sevmeyen yapılı ve enerji
içeriği oldukça zengin olan organik
moleküller Biz de ne yapıyoruz deri
altımızda bunu depoluyor hatta fazla
aldığımız bazı besinleri de yağa çevirip
deri altında depoluyor ne demiştik
hatırlarsanız bir şekilde proteinlerin
karbohidrat lın fazlası Yağlara
çevrilerek depolanabilir met ol ik
yapısal düzenleyici pek çok işi var
düzenleyici dediğimizde hormonlar
aklınıza gelebilir steroid hormonlar
östrojen progesteron Testosteron
aldosteron kortizol gibi hormonlar
bunları endokrin sistemde ileride
duyacaksınız hücre zarının bileşeni
fosfolipitler Bunu da çok sık
duyacaksınız arkadaşlar ama bu yılın
sorusu polimer değildir çıktı sınavda
polimer neydi n tane bileşik birbirine
benzeyen yapıda ve bunlar yan yana
geliyor bağ oluşturarak çok daha büyük
bir yapı oluşturuyor bunların yüzlercesi
binlercesi mesela glikozun aminoasitin
yan yana gelerek işte nişasta glikojen
sellos kitin protein polipeptitler
oluştururken lipitlerde işte 3 ya asiti
bir gliserol 2 ya asiti bir gliserol bir
fosfat Bunlar polimer değildir
arkadaşlar hücre ve dokuların
birbirleriyle haberleşmesinde önemli rol
oynarlar yine endokrin yapıyı
düşünebilirsiniz ama hücre içerisinde
ikincil haberci sistemi var Özellikle
ileride tıp fakültesine gitmeyi düşünen
arkadaşlar biyokimya derslerinde
fizyoloji derslerinde ve farmakoloji
derslerinde ikincil habercileri
görecekler mesela hücre zarından bazı
enzimler parça koparacak ve içeride onu
başka bir maddeye çevirecek Ağrı kesiler
Tutun da birçok arkadaşlar ilacın etki
mekanizması burayı
hedefleyen yağların ve fosfolipitlerin
yapısına katılan yağ asitlerinden
bahsedelim lipitlerin Temel yapı taşı
hücrelerde serbest olabilir ama dediğim
gibi yağ asitleri gliserole bağlanıp
nötral yağları ya da fosfolipidleri
oluşturabilir birazdan bunu detaylandı
yağ asitlere Doymuş ve doymamış yağ
asitleri olmak üzere temelde iki gruptur
karbonları arasında şu şekilde çift bağ
görüyorsanız bu doymamıştım
Eğer görmüyorsanız bu
Doymuş lütfen şu şuraya bakarak hocam
Burada da çiti bağ demeyin çünkü
karbonlar arasında dedim tamam karbon
oksijen arasında değil buralar karboksil
grupları karbon zincirleri Bir de şöyle
güzel bir soru tipi var mesela eşit
sayıda karbon içeren yağ asitlerinden
hangisinde daha çok hidrojen vardır
Doymuş da mı doymamış da mı Doymuş
hidrojenle doyurulmuş o şekilde
düşünebilirsiniz onda Tabii ki daha çok
Hidrojen bağı var çünkü bakın çift bağ
Yani şöyle gözünüzle canlandır ben en
iyisi karbon 4 bağ yapar Hocam şu
hidrojen hidrojen hidrojen hidrojen
doğru mu karbon 4 bağ
yapıyorsa Eğer Burası çift bağ değil tek
bağa düşerse bakın Burada 4 tane
hidrojen var Burada 6 tane hidrojen var
Doymuş yağ asidinde eşit sayıda karbon
içeren bahsediyorum daha çok Hidrojen
bağı var peki Doymuş oda sıcaklığında
katığı genellikle hayvansal tereyağı iç
yağı kuyruk yağı doymamış oda
sıcaklığında sıvı genellikle bitkisel
nedir işte zeytinyağı ay çik yağı
vesaire margarinler oda sıcaklığında
katı olan ve hidrojenle doyurulmuş
bitkisel yağlardır Burada da şöyle bir
mantık var Mesela diyelim ki bir tank
içerisine işte uygun sıcaklık sıvı yağ
koydunuz sonra içerisine hidrojeni
gönderdiniz buradaki çift bağ kırılıyor
ne oluyor arkadaşlar tekli bağ yani sıvı
katıya dönüşüyor ama margarinler o kadar
kötüdür ki arkadaşlar üstüne Sinek bile
konmaz karınca gelmez ama her zararlı
şey gibi bunun da tadı güzel
trigliseritler nötral yağlar tri 3
oradan aklınızda Kalsın 3 yağ asidi bir
gliserol şu şekilde yazalım 3 yağ
asidi bir
gliserol 1 nötral yağ 3 mol su şu
şekilde hocam 3 su çıktı çünkü bağ kadar
su çıkar arkadaşlar bakın hidroksil
hidroksil hidroksil burada karboksil
gruplarıyla bağ yapıp Ester bağı
oluşturacak gliserol bir alkol türevidir
gliserole 3 yağ asiti bağladığınız zaman
adı trigliserit yani nötral yağ işte
Bunu biz Dep oluyoruz tamam mı ancak
buraya baktığınızda ne var gliserole İki
yağ asidi Bir de fosfat bağlanmış işte
bunun adı fosfolipit ve bu nerededir
hocam hücre zarının ana yapısını ana
iskeletini oluşturur fosfolipitler le
nötral yağ arasındaki farkı gördünüz
nötral yağda bir tane ekstradan yağ
asidi var fosfolipitte ise o yağ
asidinin yerine ne var fosfat grubu var
işte lipitlerde karbon hidrojen oksijen
yine bulunacak ama bazılarında fosfor ve
azot da var diyeceksiniz işte fosfolipit
Hatta buradaki fosfat gruplarına azot
grupları da bağlanıyor Kolin bazı olarak
internette aratırsanız bir şeyler
görürsünüz arkadaşlar yani bunlar da
azotta bulunabiliyor ama bence çok daha
önemli bir bilgi O da işte Burada hücre
zarında iki katmanlı bir layer ya da
çift katmanlı duruyorlar nasıl Hocam
bakın şu şekilde fosfolipidin baş kısmı
hidrofilik filum sevmek demek kuyruk
kısmı hidrofobik hocam benim fobilerim
var korkuyorum bak sudan kaçan suyu
sevmeyen demek yağ asidinden oluşan
kuyruklar suyu sevmiyor ama fosfat
gruplarından oluşan hidrofilik baş suyu
seviyor Dolayısıyla hücrenin dışındaki
ekstraselüler sıvıyla hücrenin
içerisindeki sitoplazmaya temas halinde
olanlar baş kısımları baş grupları
hidrofilik gruplar Ama bakın sudan kaçan
yapılar içeri doğru dönüyor ve bu
şekilde hücre zarının ana yapısı
oluşturulmuş olunuyor Demek ki
fosfolipitler hücre zarının olmazsa
olmazı steroidler ünlemi atmışım hocam
Bak bunlar halkasal yapılar Az önce sen
nötral yağları ve fosfolipidleri
anlatırken gliserol var dedin Ester bağı
var dedin yağ asitleri var dedin çok
göreceksiniz bu soruyu steroidlerin
yapısında bakın halkasal yapılar var ve
bunlarda yağ
asidi
gliserol Ester bağı gibi şeyler olmaz bu
yapılara baktığınızda Tabii düzenleyici
ifadesini bunlarla eşleştirir Çünkü
hormon sistemi ile alakalıdır önce
Şunlara bakalım en bilinen steroid
moleküller kim kolesterol steroid
hormonlar safra asitleri D vitamini önce
saydığım kolesterol türevi steroid
türevi hormonlar östrojen progesteron
Testosteron aldosteron kortizol gibi
yapılar arkadaşlar Çok kıymetli çok
önemli şimdi kolesterole baktığımız
zaman hücre zarının akışkanlığı için çok
önemli arkadaşlar kolesterol işte çok
kötüdür vücudumuzu almayalım tarzında
bir cümle sakın kurmayın her şeyin
Fazlası zarar olduğu gibi tabii ki bunun
da fazlası zarar olduğu için Evet
fazlasıyla ilgili problemimiz var ama
sizin beyniniz mesela inanılmaz derecede
yağ içeriyor Şimdi ben yağsız mı
beslenmeliyim İnsanların en fazla
yaptığı hatalardan bir tanesi kendi
kafalarına göre diyet yapmaları bu tarz
yapılan diyetler her zaman
başarısızlıkla sonuçlanır ve hem
sağlığını hem de beden görüntüsünü
kaybeder o iyi görüntüyü kaybeder
insanlar ne yapıyorlar en büyük hata ne
işte ben Hiç karbohidrat yemiyorum hocam
ya da ben hiç yağı ağzıma sürmüyorum
hocam böyle bir şey yok böyle bir dünya
yok karbohidrat yemezsen yağları
yakamazsın biyokimyada çok tatlı bir
cümle vardır yağlar karbonhidratların
ateşinde Yanar Bu bir İkincisi yağsız
beslenme diye bir şey olmaz çünkü
esansiyel temel yağ asitleri diye bir
şey var hocam Bak burada hemen oraya
dönelim esansiyel Elzem temel mesela
Omega 3 gibi Omega 6 gibi yağ asitleri
Sen üretemez içinde esansiyel ve temel
kelimesi geçiyorsa bunları dışarıdan
alman lazım ve Ayrıca yağda çözünen
vitamin diye bir kavram var Dolayısıyla
Sen yağ almazsan vücuduna yeterli
vitamin de alamazsın Bunu ileride
öğreteceğim adek vitaminleri adek
vitaminleri yağda çözünerek vücuda
alınır ve kolesterol zarın akışkanlığı
için önemlidir hücre zarında aşırı
sıcakta sıvılaşmaya aşırı soğukta
katılaşmaya engelleyen fosfolipitlerin
arasındaki mesafeyi düzenleyen bir
yapıdan bahsediyoruz kolesterol çok
kıymetli O yüzden işte bu terz
kavramları duyduğunuzda ön yargıyla
sakın yaklaşmayın hocam diğer derslerde
bize şöyle bir şey söyledin suyun da
fazlası zararlı değil mi vitaminlerin de
fazlası zararlı her şeyin fazlası
zararlı ama kararını da almak zorundayız
Arkadaşlar dikkat edelim tamam mı D
vitamini kemik sağlığını korumada
kalsiyum metabolizmasında görevli önemli
bir yapı safra asitleri yağları mekanik
olarak sindirecek Bun ne demek olduğunu
ileride Sindirim sistemini öğretirken
söyleyeceğim tekrar ve dediğim gibi
steroid hormonlar östrojen progesteron
Testosteron aldosteron kortizol gibi
hormonlar Bunlar da metabolizmamız için
çok kıymetli Evet lipitleri bitirdik
Arkadaşlar yarın da protein videosu
gelecek Umarım anlaşılmıştır hepinize
kolay gelsin
[Müzik]